рідкісний момент Една не в євросоюзі
на саміті 27 28 держав голосує за перо
лайки отуско
вище польща та й у батьківщину смугу та
про ти і обіцяючи блоку вати подалі і
рішення євро саміту
у нинішнього польського кору вниз твій
акіко причиною любить зі співачки знака
paper feed us вченому позитивну доу
ряду партії грому диска платформа
подругами штучками сірим кардиналом
польші ярославом качинським давньою
неприязні
бабій шоу варшаві до себе зла не на
туска через те ще тій раніше п'ятьом у
літніх та супроводі брус цілому
санкції проти з чим забажаєш складу
хінгана мабуть залишилося а
прибрав іполити каяки і порушив усі
принципи через на вали дун і не особливо
його принцип нейтралітету вин знайдуть риба
вся нейтралітет u-wing у працю та вся а
всередині шні польські справи задуха грубі
способи
чомусь спосіб радикальні їм теж не
його в пошуку виправивши, але ж після
параска на голос біля вані запасу духу лави
європейської ради варшава здавалася не
обирає team вона панувала диму
шпроти через те, що з'явився на знак протесту
напиши стильну заяву саміту з і таким
чином продовжу курс на саму ізоляцію
кутимо бездарності єдиної Європи з пукани
завантажу і на яблучка місяць через те
ще в Європі вибору хвала не за
довіднику проточного ділових рішень
на плані і шукати блокада поки
не почала спливаючи за символічно акція
акція свій видного політичного
божевілля ama клявся що правда не все
політичні сили в пущі
і приймуть таку лінію про влючаю партії
он і на розумієте Європу в вони нас
приймають Європу з правду кажеш і
сипуха на для качинського я боюся наша
ситуація схожа на хмару Великобританії так
все розпливлося
з університету ясний активних розломів
проїзд і потім процесу виходу з
виправи відкритий конфлікт перо лайка
дональд туск за клік варшава він з їжі
подалі розкол
у середині євросоюзу приймай буде нього
Європи на саміті в Римі